stunning New Revelations and another
possible connection between suspected
killer Brian coburger and college
students killed at the University of
Idaho sources tell People magazine that
in the weeks leading up to the November
slangs in Moscow suspect Brian coburger
ate at the restaurant where two of the
victims worked a former employee at the
Mad Greek says that coburger came in at
least twice he stood out because of his
strict vegan diet now it's unclear if
either Madison Mogan or Zana kernodle
ever waited on coburger law enforcement
told people that they're aware of the
visits and are collecting surveillance
video this Revelation comes just days
after a source said that coburger had
Direct messaged at least one of the
victims on Instagram multiple times but
never got a response Kaylee gonsalves
Madison Logan zonner kernodle and Ethan
Chapin were stabbed to death in their
off-campus home more than a month later
coburger was arrested at his parents
home in Pennsylvania he'd been attending
Washington State University pursuing a
PhD PhD in criminology he was extradited
back to Idaho and now faces murder
charges
my co my co-host Brian buckmeyer Terry
Austin the join me now it's good to see
you both Terry I'll start with you
social media may have led coburger
straight to the victims but the question
now is what can people do what can they
do to protect themselves on platforms
like Tick Tock and Instagram well
the media did lead the investigators to
coburger or led coburger to the victims
but we do know that you can protect
yourselves you can be self-protective in
other words don't put personally
identifiable information on your social
media there's no reason to put your date
of birth down for any app that you're
using and there's no reason to put the
location on unless you are in a lift and
someone needs to find you so that's the
first thing the other thing is that
social media companies should be held
responsible for some of the content that
goes on right now there's a federal law
section 230 and it says that social
media content is just something that the
individuals who post are now responsible
for so there are things that you can do
well hopefully people take that advice
Brian let's just go back to coburger for
a second because every week we learn a
little bit more about his connections to
the victims how is this going to affect
the June preliminary hearing that we
talked about well Jesse I think it's all
going to come in the preliminary hearing
isn't just based on what they knew at
the time of his arrest or when he was
rained it's everything coming up to that
June 26th and hey I've been trying to
find angles I know I'm the resident
defense attorney here
but as a circumstantial evidence starts
to pile on top of itself I cannot see a
way out for Brian coburger here it seems
like every angle every bit of
information every little bit of source
is pointed to the direction that he's a
predator and might have been stalking
his prey never good when Brian buckmeyer
can't find a defense that's always bad
news I should tell you that long crime
daily has also learned that the judge in
Layton County Idaho has amended the gag
order that was already in place you see
the updated order now prohibits
attorneys representing the victim's
families from discussing anything about
the case publicly you might recall that
when co-worker was arrested in December
the judge put an order in place saying
that anyone involved with the case like
attorneys in law enforcement couldn't
talk to the media but now that extends
to the families of Kaylee Madison Zano
and Ethan this comes after interviews
from outspoken parents and lawyers were
seen by people all over the world the
order lasts until there's a verdict or
the judge decides to amend the order
again